What we just said,
with the web application and
the reading input from a form and
then generating a query,
let's do an example based on that.
So let's say this web
application is running, and
user is going to provide input.
The input they provide is,
let's say the city Redmond.
So if that's the case,
the script is going to generate
the query that says select
star from OrdersTable.
If you go back and
look at the code where basically it's
going to replace the placeholder that we
had for Shipcity by this input that
was just provided by the user.
The script generating this.
And this is what is going to
get submitted to the database.
Now let's get to what kind of mischief
a user who's malicious may do.
So, what if the user, instead of
providing Redmond, is going to provide
something that says Redmond Code,
semi colon, drop table orders table,
drop, this is the particular
table that we're talking about.
What if they entered this whole thing?
Okay, so before we look at this
maybe a little bit of SQL here.
So semicolon separates the statement,
so this statement will end here.
And the next statement is a drop table,
orders table and
drop results in basically, assuming
that you have access to do that,
deletion off this particular table.
So what happened here is that the user
is actually entering a lot more
input than what we expect,
which is just a city name.
So what happens when the user
actually provides this as input?
They're injecting this SQL
injection that we're talking about,
you'll see where
the name now comes from.
In this case the query that we're
going to generate is going to be
this, actually.
So, what this is what we got before.
This is what we're going to get
now because here we're going to
replace the Shipcity variable
value that we read is this one.
So now, essentially we're
giving the database this query.
And now you can see what
really has happened here.
The malicious user that we have is able
to inject code to delete the table,
and that is what we see here after the
semicolon, we see a DROP OrdersTable,
and that's what we generate, and this
will result in deletion of this table.
So, this is the injection.
We're injecting code through input,
that is normally expected
by the web application.
The vulnerability we have in
the web application is that it's
not checking input obviously.
It is accepting this input for
cities where the item is shipped.
Getting a name of course, but
it also there's lot more
stuff that comes after that.
It is accepting this input,
and this input is not correct input
when we looking for just the city name.
So, by providing this input,
it's able to inject malicious code to
drop the table or to delete the table.
This is going to impact its integrity.
And that's actually a concrete
example of what SQL injections are